we're gonna lure our co-workers down to
the front desk and they are gonna think
that they're getting a special package
from Marnie but in actuality me and
Kelly have designed an elaborate vampire
attack to happen right here behind them
and they're gonna freak out so the
actors gonna come here fight me on the
neck I'm gonna cough up fake blood let's
see oh thank you but oh thank you for
meeting with me so we're doing the date
on Wednesday actually I just want to
make sure all right they were cooler
like do the interview
[Music]
[Applause]
this is too much this is a Friday and
I'm over stimulated I need to go grab
something else let me just go grab a
peak thank you for doing the video we're
gonna do the date next weekend I wonder
like maybe we could do like the
interview first make sure okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so I came downstairs for a package and
then all the sudden this guy just bites
Ryan and for five seconds I'm like this
isn't real right now
life isn't real right now I don't do
supernatural I don't dance with the
devil Lucifer could stay at his house no
we tried to scare everyone in our office
and lure them down here I'm at least one
of my co-workers scares but
[Music]
you
[Music]